Hi.
My name is Daniel Rodriguez.
And today I will
show you how to build
games and interactive
applications
for the living room using Google
Cast and the Game Manager APIs.
There are millions
of Cast devices
ready for your amazing games.
The Cast model introduces a
new exciting game experience.
Players can use their phones
as dynamic game controllers
with the TV.
There's a lot of opportunity
for innovation here.
Mobile devices have powerful
sensors and touch screens
that we can use
to our advantage.
Just imagine advancing through
a dungeon with your friends,
using your phone screen to draw
arcane symbols to cast spells
while your body physically
runs around the living room
to cast a protective
shield around you.
In order to build that
kind of experience,
all the devices need
to share information.
Thankfully, you won't
have to spend your time
writing and testing code
to synchronize them.
The Game Manager API helps
you with this, particularly
in the case where
the Cast device is
responsible for
rendering on the TV
and hosting the majority
of the game logic.
Getting your game
ready for Google Cast
means understanding three
parts of the Game Manager API.
First we have Senders.
These are the player's mobile
phones, tablets, or laptops.
Android, iOS, and Chrome
are all supported.
Next, we have the Cast Receiver.
That's the TV connected with a
Cast device, like a Chromecast.
Finally, there is information
exchange between the senders
and the receivers.
There are a bunch of
different game types
that can take advantage
of the Game Manager API,
from turn based to real
time game play, which
is why we support
the ability to have
multiple players on a
single sender device.
And all of these
APIs can be used
in combination with
Google Play game services
to implement features like
leaderboards and achievements.
So here's how it works.
All the synchronization
between players
is handled through
the Cast receiver.
You know, like a Chromecast
connected to your TV.
This acts like a
server for the match
and will store the
game state, and will
take the role of
pushing notifications
to devices once the
information is available.
Players can make requests
to change their state
and send game messages
to the receiver.
Player's state can be
used to implement features
like a lobby system.
It is also used to indicate that
a player has been disconnected
and to reconnect that player.
Let's look at the APIs
for sender devices.
The sender APIs are available
on Android, iOS, and Chrome,
and work the same
across platforms.
All request operations
performed by the sender device
are asynchronous.
To connect the sender
and register a player,
first, you must
initialize the Cast SDK.
Check out our dev site
to get more information.
Once this is done, you'll be
ready to request a Game Manager
Client instance.
It contains a copy of the entire
state on the receiver device
and will be updated
automatically.
From this point on, you
can read the current state,
send game messages, and
make player requests.
A player request is a message
used to register new players
and change their player state.
A game message represents
player's actions.
Its contents are
entirely up to your game.
The Game Manager
Client always has
a snapshot of the
receiver state,
and it's updated automatically.
This means you can query
any value at any time,
like the number of players
or the lobby state.
You can attach a listener to get
notified when something changes
or when a game
message is received.
Now let's look at the receiver
APIs for the HTML5 game running
on the Google Cast device.
This is my favorite
part, since this
is where the majority
of the game code lives.
To get started, follow
instructions on our dev site
about how to set up a receiver
and then construct the Game
Manager object.
Unlike the sender APIs,
all operations you perform
are synchronous since everything
happens on the same device.
When you update any piece
of Game Manager state,
a message will be
sent automatically
to all connected senders
letting them know of the change.
Much like on the
sender APIs, you
can set up listeners to get
notified of state changes
and game messages.
To send messages to
players, you just
have to specify the
player ID and the message.
We'll take care of the rest.
But we can't write perfect
code every time, right?
To debug your game, you can
connect the Chrome Remote
Debugger just like with
any other Cast application.
You can enable a debug UI
that is displayed on top
of your game on the TV screen.
We also provide you
with a debugging app
for Android and
iOS that allows you
to see the game state and
messages being passed around,
as well as connect new
players and update them.
To help you get started, we
have open source game samples
that you can use for reference.
Make sure to check them out.
In summary, we provide you with
the Receiver SDK, the Sender
SDKs for Android,
iOS, and Chrome,
sample games that
help you get started,
game debugger apps, and a
debug UI for the receiver,
UX guidelines for Cast
games, and all of the SDK
documentation and reference.
There are other ways you
can use to create games
with the power of Google Cast.
If you want to have a phone or
a tablet host the game logic
and push content
to a TV, check out
the DevBytes video about
Remote Display for Google Cast.
We're excited to see what
kind of innovative games
you'll build using the Game
Manager APIs for Google Cast.
Don't forget to check our dev
site to get more information.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]